For this inequality, the interval would be negative infinity to negative 3,
union 2 to positive infinity. Great solving if you found those two regions.
When we find the solution set for a quadratic inequality, we first want to
start by finding the zeros. These are the x values that make the equation equal
to 0. We factor this quadratic using x plus 3 times x minus 2 as the factors,
then we set each factor to equal to 0 to get x equals negative 3 and x equals
positive 2. We use these x values to set up our three intervals, so we know the
values of x might be less than negative 3, between negative 3 and 2, or greater
than 2. These different regions are the possible solutions to our inequality.
We test the value in the first interval to see if it makes the inequality true.
I'm going to choose the value x equals negative 4. Plugging in negative 4 for
x, we'll get 6 is greater than 0, which we know is a true statement. This
means, any value less than negative 3 will make this inequality true. And
notice, we've already got our first interval. Negative infinity to negative 3,
here. We need to test the value now for interval II. I'll use x equals 0, since
that's pretty easy to plug in and evaluate. If x is equal to 0, then these two
terms would drop out. They would just be 0. And we'd be left with negative 6 is
greater than 0. We know this statement is not true. So this region is false. We
exclude it from our solution set. And finally, we try a different value of x
for our third interval. I'll use x equals 3. When we plug in x equals 3, here
and here, we'll get the statement 6 is greater than 0. This is true. This means
any value greater than 2 will satisfy our original inequality. And notice we
have our second region. From 2 all the way up to positive infinity.